[Music]
here's an article john from fox business
by now pay later expanding to
storefronts and gas pumps
that's right so buy now pay later has
become increasingly popular in recent
years expected to reach 680 billion
dollars in transaction volume across the
world by 2025. and as kovid has forced
many consumers to shop online more the
use of buy now pay later
obviously began to rise so let's pay for
net let's pay next month for last
month's trip that's what we're seeing
buy now pay later provider zip formerly
quad pay has a partnership with chevron
allowing drivers to pay for their gas in
four installment payments over a six
week span
wow
this is scary john
yeah because you're still driving all
those other times
you're paying for gas that happened
three weeks ago but you filled up twice
since then and so you're now you're
paying for gas two weeks ago and a week
ago
all to kick the can down the road we're
gonna build quad pay some huge shiny new
buildings yep and their executives are
gonna be driving a bunch of fancy new
teslas
because
we find ourselves in this mess and
klarna and affirm and after pay i mean
the list of companies just keeps on
growing who people who are getting in on
this and what's hilarious john not so
hilarious not so fun fact another
article from fox business says this more
than a quarter of consumers can't afford
their buy now pay later payments of
course that's right it's not magic debt
hammer survey found that 30 of
respondents have struggled to make their
buy now pay later payments and have
therefore had to skip paying a bill for
essentials utilities rent mortgage car
to avoid defaulting
this is bad
if you can't pay for your four walls but
you're paying quad pay for your gas
you have a huge problem
and here's what i found john klarna
brags on their website this is hilarious
they brag to the retailers that
consumers spend 45 percent more
when you include a buy now pay later
service on your website when under that
40 add to cart it says 10 easy payments
right four easy payments of ten dollars
to pay for that forty dollar item it's
it's a
more subversive
um predatory practice for people who are
really desperate and struggling and it's
stealing from the least of these in our
communities and it's taking capital out
of low income communities it's taking
the the hard work i mean these people
are working themselves to death in these
hourly wage jobs and these type of
companies they're like payday lenders
except now it's much more sophisticated
it's fancy and
you don't have to have the shame of
driving into a
petty lender place and walk in with your
head held low and and sign away you just
got to push the button when you mix all
this debt with convenient payment
methods and effortless i mean that's
literally apple pays tagline cashless
made effortless yeah they want it to be
effortless think less about what you're
doing feel it less yes
it makes me ill because this is one of
those things that is
just preying on folks who are hurting
right now and i
hate it hate it hate it i hate it
and it doesn't hey there's the thing i
don't have i do none of us do we don't
have magic solutions for the gas pump we
don't have magic solutions for
inflation right now i mean the ship's
out in the heart out of the harbor right
now
there's a couple of you got to earn more
or spend less or have some people in
your life that are generous that can
right there's some hard decisions we all
got to make
but this is predatory but paying quad
pay before your light bill that's not
okay don't do that fine margin in your
budget i don't care what it takes stay
away from these predatory lenders
even though they're shiny and they tell
you that they want to create financial
freedom quote unquote for everyone
that's what they're using they're using
language like we would use right create
breathing room in your budget if you are
a person of means if you're not a person
stuck on the margins who's struggling
refuse to use these services because
they're making their money on the backs
of people who are broke and who are
hurting and who are left aside don't
support this crap i'm not gonna get
pisses me off man because it's it's
those like i can go do this and i'll pay
the bill next month and i'll go wow
that's expensive and i'll pay the bill
the month after that they're not going
to make any money off me they're going
to make money off those who can't so
let's don't support this thing and it
will implode on itself and i hate it i
hate it i hate it i hate it these
younger generations are the ones falling
for it and they see it like well it's
better than a credit card yeah buy now
pay later it's better than credit card
i'm making my payments it's a more
predatory credit card i think yeah
golly don't do it people avoid buying
out pay later at all costs and hey let
me say this if your company is based on
stealing from hurting people
stop
stop
stop
that's it i hope that worked i hope
after pay goes hey john we heard you on
the ramsay show we're shutting it down
one of their not they're as seniors
because they're tied in somebody riding
to work is going to get a clip and
they're going to know what they're doing
is wrong yeah they're going to know what
they're doing is wrong and they're going
to say hey at least i can't be a part of
this right yeah go check out the fine
print episode on buy now pay later that
we did it was eye opening we shared some
stories we talked to experts go check it
out it's called a firm clara after pay
should you buy now pay later